[Music]  hi I'm Claudette Cepeda Wilkins chef and  restaurant owner today we're making  Thanksgiving dinner  thanks to Google's new smart display the  Google Home Hub James and Haley can help  me make the site hey Google cook with  tasty welcome back to tasty what would  you like to make today corn and chorizo  stuffing sure here you go are you so  going good now they're teenagers they  don't like really get in the kitchen  with me but the Google home hub makes it  fun and we're together in the kitchen  what do you have in your mouth usually  during Thanksgiving dinner my mom and  Hailey are the ones that helped me the  most  James is usually playing video game I'm  watching watching football hey Google  how do you chopped cilantro okay playing  cooking tips how to chop cilantro in  YouTube  hey Google how many Ounces you're gonna  cut one u.s. cup equals eight US fluid  ounces  [Music]  you